bien écoutez si vous voulez bien nous
allons commencer cette audition et je
vais commencer par vous remercier
d'avoir
répondu à cette invitation pour échanger
sur la question de l'eau donc nous avons
aujourd'hui à 17h une audition avec
Monsieur André Bernard vice-président de
la PCA
et présidente de la Chambre
d'Agriculture de PACA
accompagné de garants
chargé de mission au à la PCA
donc merci de votre présence et de
consacrer un petit peu de temps pour
cette audition d'ailleurs qui fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo m'a-t-on
dit et qui donc vise à éclairer les
membres de la cette mission
d'information de l'eau qui était lancée
par le Sénat début février donc vous
voyez que ça fait déjà certains nombre
de mois que nous travaillons nous
faisons des auditions et à la demande au
groupe socialiste du Sénat et c'est donc
une mission transpartisane où tous les
groupes politiques sont représentés le
rapporteur est donc Hervé gilet sénateur
de Gironde qui connaît parfaitement tous
ces problèmes de l'eau étant appliqués
dans les
toutes les
associations de concernant l'eau dans le
département de Gironde
et de dans ce temps donc il s'agit de
vous entendre en tant qu'expert
sachant que comme vous le savez le
changement climatique
nous met en tension dans le domaine de
l'eau et ces deux dernières années 2022
et 2023 qui continue en termes de
sécheresse estivale puisqu'on alors
peut-être pas trop dans le dans le sud
depuis quelques jours puisque je crois
qu'il est tombé des grandes quantités
d'eau mais enfin c'est pas ça qui va
remonter les nappes malheureusement
donc ce que nous souhaitons savoir c'est
par rapport à ce que l'on travaille que
vous faites dans les champs
d'agriculture en a auditionné déjà
beaucoup de
d'organismes agricoles des syndicats
agricoles les coopératives les
semenciers les syndicats d'irrigans donc
vous voyez qu'on a fait beaucoup pour
aussi le domaine agricole
les objectifs d'abord est-ce qu'ils
soient adaptés pour concernant la
ressource en eau les instruments
juridiques
organisationnels ou encore financiers de
la politique de l'eau est-ce qu'ils sont
et efficients
que faut-il changer pour gérer au mieux
la ressource en eau à l'échelle
nationale mais également territoriale
pour atteindre les objectifs de qualité
de quantité et pour assurer la
conciliation de la pluralité des usages
de l'eau voici nos préoccupations et
aujourd'hui on voudrait vous entendre
plus particulièrement sur l'usage
agricole bien sûr de l'eau
en mettant en accent l'accent sur
l'irrigation et la problématique que je
sais sensible qui sont les réserves de
substitution
sur la manière manière également de
mener à bien les concertations locales
autour d'un
usage raisonné de l'eau qui assure à la
fois la pérennité de l'activité agricole
et le partage équitable d'une ressource
qui malheureusement se rarifie donc
voilà en quelques mots la présentation
de notre mission et je vais laisser la
parole à mon collègue Hervé gilet qui va
continuer dans son domaine de question
et de peut-être que vous présenterez
après si vous le permettez pour
cette audition importante aussi merci
monsieur le Président cher ami on vous
tiens à vous remercier bien sûr pour
votre disponibilité remercier aussi à
mes collègues d'être assez nombreux pour
cette audition
vous donner quelques éléments peut-être
de là où nous nous situons par rapport
au déroulé de la mission d'information
ce qui vous permettra de comprendre
d'ores et déjà quels sont les les enjeux
ou les sujets sur lesquels il nous
semble important d'approfondir nos
travaux et sans doute nous propositions
la confrontation bien sûr d'une
gouvernance par bassin tout le monde
s'accorde à ce niveau là et cette
confrontation
s'appuyant bien sûr sur les comités de
bassins et les agences de l'eau
interrogent quand même la qualité des
gouvernances même à l'échelle des
comités de bassins qui parfois sont un
peu lourds pas suffisamment partagé mais
il peut y avoir quelques questionnements
aujourd'hui à ce niveau là
la gouvernance par bassin pour
l'améliorer il faut améliorer aussi la
connaissance de la ressource disponible
ce qui n'est pas toujours le cas en fait
donc il faut améliorer les systèmes les
bases de données et d'analyses beaucoup
plus fine de la connaissance des
ressources toutes les nappes ne sont pas
encore forcément bien connues notamment
les nappes souterraines aujourd'hui mais
pas que et la nature de fonctionnement
des nappes n'est pas toujours bien
maîtrisée encore aujourd'hui or on
s'aperçoit qu'il y a une singularité qui
s'affirme de plus en plus quand on met
en place un projet un projet souvent il
est singularisé par son environnement
par son territoire il n'y a pas de dogme
qui s'applique mais il y a forcément des
études spécifiques de singularité à
mettre en place encore faut-il en avoir
les moyens meilleure connaissance de la
ressource mes meilleures connaissances
aussi des consommations ce qui là
également n'est pas toujours le cas et
encore des trous dans la raquette pour
affiner véritablement la connaissance au
niveau de la ressource car si on veut
améliorer la gouvernance et notamment
l'approche négociée et partagée de la
ressource à l'échelle d'un bassin encore
faut-il bien maîtriser ces sujets là et
ça semble partager par l'ensemble des
partis prenantes aujourd'hui mais ça
veut dire quand même des investissements
et des travaux importants pour améliorer
cette connaissance la gouvernance par
bassin il faudra la croiser avec les
politiques territoriales comment les
politiques territoriales déclinent
également les objectifs de la
gouvernance par bassin à tous les
niveaux la région dans l'accompagnement
des filières économiques quelles
qu'elles soient industrielles mais
évidemment agricoles toutes les régions
n'ont pas forcément contractualisées au
niveau des fonds européens pour
accompagner la profession agricole dans
tous les domaines où les domaines
possibles donc il y a une question de
déclinaison des politiques territoriales
l'implication donc des régions dans le
caractère économique mais de
planification vous voyez bien qu'au
niveau des stradettes aujourd'hui il y a
éléments de planification qui monte
aussi en puissance pour voir comment ils
arrivent ensuite sur le terrain la
réinterrogation du positionnement des
conseils départementaux pour les
resécuriser sur une partie de leur de
leur engagement ou de leur compétences
parce que la loi nôtre aimable avait
induit un certain nombre
d'interrogations juridiques or
l'ingénierie de proximité peut être
particulièrement utile dans
l'accompagnement au niveau des
territoires donc aujourd'hui on
réinterroge
derrière c'est l'amélioration ou des
préconisations pour que la science
fondamentale la science appliquée et
ensuite
la cristallisation sur les process
industriels se déroulent dans les
meilleures conditions or le système
national semble assez complexe en fait
sur les moyens qui sont alloués et
comment c'est mon lien sont alloués dans
un meilleur bénéfice et ça interroge
aussi le poids des régions dans ce cadre
de figure
on ira sans doute vers une affirmation
de la déclinaison de la gestion de l'eau
dans les politiques d'urbanisme les
scottes et les pluies puisque notamment
sur les scottes la meilleure des façons
d'accueillir les populations c'est aussi
de s'interroger sur la ressource
disponibles mais également sur une
meilleure gestion de cette ressource
dans la permababilisation des sols les
stratégies qu'on peut avoir de zones
humides à l'échelle des scottes et donc
d'être aussi dans un processus négocié
territorial dans ce cas de figure
sur les pluies des meilleures stratégies
sur l'eau pluviale notamment parce que
souvent l'eau pliviale est rejeté dans
des réseaux séparatifs avec un manque
d'approche stratégique il faut peut-être
reprendre des pratiques pour injecter
l'eau dans des milieux ordinaires et
peut-être avoir d'autres stratégies du
meilleur utilisation du pluvial et donc
il faut l'inscrire aussi dans les pluies
aujourd'hui pour accompagner accompagner
effectivement
ces politiques derrière il y a les
grands cycles il y a le petit cycle bien
sûr derrière le petit si qui a les zones
de captage
inévitablement une augmentation des
zones de protection des zones de captage
et derrière l'augmentation des zones de
protection des zones de captage comment
finance les services rendus et notamment
les services rendus agricoles comme en
place des politiques d'acceptabilité
voire même si on peut arriver vers des
économies un peu plus circulaires autour
de la protection des zones de captage
comme le font parfois exemple Paris ou
l'Île-de-France ça pourrait être
intéressant à certains moments d'avoir
des productions qui reviennent aussi sur
un cycle territorial mais c'est plus
facile à dire qu'à faire mais en tout
cas ce sont des sujets qui sont
forcément si posées sur la table bien
sûr la réutilisation des eaux usées tout
le monde aujourd'hui est d'accord plus
particulièrement sur les zones
littérales mais d'ores et déjà on peut
le faire pour l'irrigation
et on s'aperçoit que c'est relativement
peu appliquer
certains endroits donc c'est aussi des
sujets qui seront travaillés je vous
donne ces éléments là pour vous fixer un
petit peu des cadres un peu de travail
je vais vous laisser la parole bien sûr
pour vous présenter
le rôle bien sûr de la Chambre
d'Agriculture France est plus
spécifiquement dans la manière dont vous
accompagnez aussi des chambres et puis
des agriculteurs sur l'évolution de ces
pratiques et puis on en est tous
conscients il y a un engagement aussi de
responsabilité de votre part sur
les nouveaux process nous assolement
comment on peut accompagner
effectivement mieux
nous sommes conscients que il y a une
volonté d'efforts mais derrière la
volonté d'efforts il faut savoir comment
on accompagne également l'évolution des
modèles économiques puisque pour pouvoir
mettre en place ou répondre à ces
nouveaux enjeux il y a aussi des
contraintes qui sont importantes donc on
est aussi conscient de cela ça suppose
aussi une réflexion sur les stratégies
d'accompagnement je vous laisse la
parole Monsieur Louis président
merci pour cette invitation
effectivement avec la somme de questions
que vous nous d'évoquer j'ai pas le
temps que nous avons mais on peut y
passer la nuit parce que ce sujet que je
connais bien et qui me passionne donc on
va essayer quand même de gagner du temps
alors peut-être d'abord pour me
présenter très rapidement donc je suis
agriculteur sur la commune d'Uchaud dans
le Vaucluse sur l'exploitation qui
produit de légumes industrie la tomate
industrie en particulier les semences
des céréales des fraises au sol et une
exploitation de serre photovoltes
henryvoltaïque voilà pour l'exploitation
donc c'est mes enfants qui sont dessus
moi aujourd'hui je fais le passage de
temps en temps et voilà bon alors après
sur mes responsabilités effectivement je
suis président vice-président national
je suis président de la Chambre régional
au sud PACA et je suis aussi président
des irigans dirigeants Méditerranée
française parce qu'il y a une
association qui a été créée il y a une
vingtaine d'années parce
qu'effectivement on avait on se
retrouvait pas forcément dans le
discours national et on avait quelques
particularités à faire passer parce que
le sud de la France est essentiellement
sur des ressources qui sont des
ressources stockées et transférées
le Verdon le Rhône qui est de l'eau qui
est stocké de l'eau alors une ressource
que je vais qualifier de renouvelable
nous sommes pas dans les prélèvements
dans des nappes profondes ce qui est que
le cas dans certaines territoires pas en
France je dis bien pas en France mais en
espagnol chercher l'eau à 300 mètres de
profondeur à propos de légumes qu'on
nous aime qu'on nous importe et qu'on
importe alors qu'on pourrait les
produire chez nous donc c'est aussi une
question après
surexploitation effectivement très
rapidement on est pratiquement tout en
irrigation parce que
produire des légumes
en régime méditerranéen sans irrigation
c'est pas peine d'y penser ça fait
peut-être la une des journaux mais ça
fonctionne pas par contre derrière les
techniques d'irrigation parce que l'eau
est très cher et l'eau pour moi il y a
un tissu je commençais l'âge de 10 ans
avec l'appel dans le champ l'eau il faut
savoir l'économiser
il faut savoir la partager mais pour
faire ça il faut qu'elle soit sécurisée
et je vais m'expliquer quand on arrosait
avec le canal on poussait l'eau jusqu'au
bout et on avait l'eau deux fois par
semaine quelques heures quelques heures
quand je me suis installé j'ai acheté
des asperceurs et un enrouleur et j'ai
arrosé par dessus à la version et là je
consommais 5 à 7000 mètres cubes à
l'hectare quelques années après je suis
passé au goutte à goutte et là je suis
tombé à 5000 mètres cubes à l'hectare et
aujourd'hui il y avait des centres de
capacités du pilotage automatisé on peut
descendre en 2500 3000 m3 voilà ce que
sur une génération on a réussi à faire
les techniques que nous déployer
aujourd'hui sur des cultures régulières
de tomates industrie ou de semences bon
ça c'est je dirais
après pour en arriver au chambrer
lecture dans la chambre de la culture
effectivement on les accompagne les
agriculteurs
à plusieurs niveaux sur la thématique de
l'eau a commencé d'abord sur la partie
conseil et accompagnement sur le plan
agronomique comment à travers des
pratiques agronomiques de travail du sol
de l'installation de couverts végétaux
de rotation ou autre on peut diminuer le
besoin d'eau pour les plantes comment on
capte on stocke l'eau dans le sol quand
il pleut donc les couverts végétaux
certaines pratiques le permettent les
paillages végétaux végétalisés au pied
des vignes au pied des arbres qui
permettent de limiter les vapo
transpiration et qui permet de garder
l'eau sous au pied
toutes ces pratiques là étant donné
déployer après sur les sur les grandes
cultures c'est pareil tout ce qui permet
de couverts végétaux qui permettent de
stocker l'eau dans le sol et du nom le
nom labour derrière avec peut-être
éventuellement un passage d'un produit
qui s'appelle glyphosate pour régler le
problème mais voilà donc si on l'avoue
on n'a pas besoin du vote mais si on
veut faire du non labour thanks
simplifié on a peut-être besoin d'un
certain moment d'un peu de glyphosate
donc ça c'est la première partie c'est
notre cœur de métier c'est l'agronomie
c'est comment on accompagne les
techniques des agriculteurs
est-ce que sur ce plan là au niveau
national vous avez une évaluation
globalement de la montée en puissance de
ce niveau de ce nouveau process en fait
est-ce que ça vous permet de
différencier un peu les territoires
certains qui doivent être plus en avance
que d'autres sur ces sur ces pratiques
effectivement il y a des il y a des
groupes d'agriculteurs qui sont plus
sensibilisés parce que pendant quelques
fois il y a la contrainte et des fois il
y a la aussi la prise de conscience
d'avancer quoi donc c'est pas homogène
sur le territoire je vous l'accorde mais
globalement c'est quand même une prise
de conscience de tout le monde de dire
aujourd'hui on sait qu'il y aura
visuellement moins d'eau demain donc si
on veut arriver à relever le défi de la
seconde alimentaire qui est quand même
notre principal motivation nous les
paysans c'est de produire pour mourir
de trouver les moyens de d'économiser
l'eau et le premier étape c'est la
partie agronomique mais ça on en est
conscient mais ce qui peut être
intéressant c'est de voir les
territoires qui sont très en avance et
les territoires qui sont un peu en
retrait sur lequel il faudra appuyer
plus fort
permettez-moi de dire regarde même que
dans le sud de la France il y a
longtemps qu'on a pris qu'on a pris
conscience de ça parce que sans
irrigation sans économie d'eau on y
arrive pas
c'est aussi le cas aujourd'hui je pense
dans les zones de
culture qui Syrie et plus plus que
d'autres parce que aussi en fonction des
évolutions de la réglementation de la
PAC il y a les régions vous êtes du
Sud-Ouest et la région qui ont développé
une plante qui fait peur à tout le monde
mais qui est quand même la plus
efficiente de toutes ces maïs mais qui a
besoin d'eau abandonné quand il entend
pas du ciel qu'il faut savoir stocker
quand elle passe au mauvais moment mais
juste là dessus on voit également que
les groupements sont souvent assez
efficaces parce qu'ils développent de
l'ingénierie de l'accompagnement etc
donc on voit qu'ils sont plus offensifs
souvent sur ces la mise en place de ces
politiques ça c'est clair on voit aussi
que quand ils sont adossés à des
contrats importants avec la filière agua
alimentaire souvent également il y a une
montée en connaissance et en capacité de
mettre en place des process qui sont
encore plus aboutis oui parce que à
partir du moment où là aussi vous faites
allusion agroalimentaire si vous n'avez
pas de contrat avec de l'agroalimentaire
vous n'avez pas de contrat avec les
semencier si vous êtes s'assurer de
pouvoir emmener la culture à terme
bonjour je suis parents Lure président
des interprofessions des fossés me
transformer on était alors en réunion
les producteurs de haricots dans le Nord
de France sont en train de rendre leur
contrat parce qu'ils ne pourront pas les
honorer parce qu'ils savent qu'ils
auront pas d'eau pour irriguer donc la
production de haricots de fin de saison
et de fin d'été à aujourd'hui est en
train de régresser parce que ils sont
pas sûr d'avoir de l'eau pour le faire
parce que ils vont arroser le poids si
elles faisaient arroser le poids ils
vont oser les pommes de terre parce que
ça arrive sur le mois de juillet mois
d'août et moi de septembre au mois
d'octobre aussi fort rosé les haricots
verts il y aura plus d'eau ou pas d'eau
donc il préfère retirer les contrats
donc les industriels ne trouvent pas le
contrat pareil en semence si vous n'avez
pas de sécuriser d'eau de l'eau on vous
donnera pas les semences de base parce
que ça coûte trop cher pour pas les
récolter là on est assez au clair par
rapport à ça nous sommes même que la
l'approche au niveau des semences c'est
sans doute un des critères de priorité
on aura l'occasion d'y revenir quand on
parle un peu des priorités aussi
d'affectation de la ressource
alors j'ai dit la partie agronomique
après il y a toute la partie je dirais
accompagnement des agriculteurs dans la
mise en conformité par rapport à la
réglementation c'est-à-dire la
déclaration de forage et les compteurs
les eaux UGC
portent la majorité des eaux UGC en
France qui permet aux agriculteurs de se
mettre en conformité pour faire une
déclaration préalable de volume
utilisable et derrière en fin de l'été
de de faire la déclaration du volume
consommé sachant que suivant le si la
demande exprimée par les agriculteurs
est supérieur à la disponibilité on fait
une gestion pour diminuer le
l'enlèvement pour essayer d'ajuster pour
pas se retrouver et des parcelles qui
seront pas irriguées donc ça c'est le
président bon on connaît tous c'est bien
le sujet il y a des chambres qui font
très bien leur boulot il y en a d'autres
qui font un peu moins parfois on a quand
même là aussi des disparités qui sont
assez importantes
c'est l'émanation de 90 chambres
départementales en gros chaque chambre
départementale sa propre autonomie c'est
pas nous qui allons faire les gendarmes
chez eux on va leur apporter les
moyennes de faire un certain nombre de
choses les accompagner dans certaines
démarches
on n'a pas autorité à les obliger par
contre on met les moyens pour les
essayer de les mettre en conformité de
les accompagner sur le plan national en
avait les départements ou en région
suivant le l'échelle du besoin oui il y
a des hétérogénéités mais ça bon
on n'est pas on n'est pas une structure
descendante dans les structures
montantes c'est le terrain qui commande
même si après derrière on a quand même
quelques orientations à donner ou
accompagnement mais on peut rien imposer
on peut pas imposer une UGC dans un
département on peut pas imposer une
gestion dans les départements c'est pas
les gens d'agriculture c'est pas comme
ça donc l'amélioration de la
connaissance de la ressource on est tous
d'accord sur l'enjeu stratégique
d'ailleurs ça mais l'amélioration de
connaissances de la consommation c'est
aussi un élément qui est déterminant
alors le système qui a été mis en place
a permis de monter en puissance à ce
niveau là mais là également sur les
prélèvements on a encore aussi des
écarts qui sont c'est important oui
alors
il y a 22 ans quand je suis arrivé un
poste à la Chambre d'Agriculture mon
premier chantier ça a été de faire le
tour du département pour l'expliquer aux
agriculteurs en Provence qu'il fallait
déclarer les forages et j'ai retrouvé
des collègues à moi que j'avais pas vu
depuis 10 ans ils m'ont dit André tu es
fou quoi là tu fais comme tu veux on
arrive avec une procédure simplifiée peu
coûteuse si tu veux il rentre dedans tu
rentres tu vas rentrer tu rentres pas tu
te débrouilleras après quand ils se font
rattraper
on a quelques cas qui ont ils ont voulu
jouer au dur et puis le jour où ils se
font rattraper
après ils prennent le responsabilités
nous en tant que chambre on a mis en
place la procédure pour les permettre de
se mettre en conformité de façon
simplifiée sur le plan administratif
parce que c'est un carcan administratif
si vous devez faire vos déclarations et
de le faire à moindre coûts parce que ça
aurait coûté pour chaque exploitation
1500 euros là ça va coûter 150 euros par
exploitation donc c'est
on a permis ça mais non oui on a
énormément de dossiers
qui ont déclaré leur forage on sait les
géolocaliser on sait le forage qui est
utilisé l'année 2023 ou 2024 parce que
le volume après pour ceux qui font la
déclaration après moi il y a des
gens qui roulent sans permis il y a des
gens qui font autre chose on n'est pas
capable non plus on n'est pas gênant oui
c'est bien l'état qui doit faire son
rôle peut-être que de venir plutôt que
de venir contrôler ceux qui sont
déclarés c'est d'aller chercher ceux qui
sont bien déclarés mais ça c'est un
autre problème il faut les aider
et après donc et après il y a surtout le
rôle des chambres de la culture je
dirais le rôle le représentation de la
profession agricole c'est à dire que
nous siions dans les toutes les
instances du du local jusqu'au régional
et à l'intérêt général et au national
dans les là où il y a des discussions
concernant l'eau
dans les petits jeux les comités locales
de l'eau les les sages ou autre les
comités sécheresses parce
qu'effectivement là aussi il faut
ajuster le niveau les agences de l'eau
et le Conseil national de l'eau donc on
est le porte-paro on représente le monde
agricole officiellement il me faisait
allusion tout à l'heure au comité de
bassins effectivement il y a pléthore de
monde dans cette affaire là il y a pas
assez de représentants professionnels
parce que ceux qui payent ceux qui
utilisent pour ceux qui paye
effectivement les consommateurs payent
aussi du consommateurs mais les
professionnels ne sont pas si
représentés
je sais que ça peut heurter mais vous me
demandez mon avis je vous le donne quand
on passe beaucoup trop de temps à
discuter pour des choses qui n'embalent
pas la peine il faut que l'avance pas
dans ce temps l'économie nous dépasse ça
c'est la partie jamais je risque d'être
un peu
rassurez-vous nous aussi rassurez-vous
nous aussi
voilà et alors après effectivement il y
a pour ceux qui sont à l'irrigation il y
a tout le travail
d'accompagnement aux nouvelles
technologies
vénétudes pour quand on veut installer
de l'irrigation sur l'exploitation on
peut les aider on peut aider aussi au
pilotage de délégation aujourd'hui nous
installons nous avons une station
expérimentale qui s'appelle le triang
qui est la gros météo et l'irrigation
qui accompagne les agriculteurs à ce
pour se former à l'usage des sons de
capacity et pour piloter à distance
l'irrigation qui permet l'agriculteur de
voir à quel moment il faut qu'il
déclenche l'irrigations et à quel moment
il arrête parce que vous sur votre
smartphone l'effet de l'irrigation dans
le sol et vous arrêtez quand vous avez
atteint la zone de confort de la plante
c'est pas la peine d'en mettre plus
longtemps par contre ça veut dire qu'il
faudra peut-être revenir plus rapidement
parce que si vous inondez le sol suivant
le type de sol vous pourrez deux jours
d'y revenir il y a des sols vous pouvez
mettre de l'eau toute la journée il y en
aura jamais trop elle va descendre donc
il faut pouvoir par contre de
fractionner pour que la zone de confort
de la plante soit humidifiée à ce
moment-là voilà en quelques mots sur
l'irrigation les au moins les quatre
entrées la technique avant
l'accompagnement des agriculteurs au
montage de dossiers financement pour
mener des investissements la
représentation des aides du monde
agricole différents niveaux et
l'accompagnement des techniques
d'irrigation
alors
allez-y mais
il y a eu certaines annonces oui
notamment au niveau du plan haut donc
aujourd'hui
la négociation qui semblerait à peu près
cristallisée c'est
que vous participiez à la diminution de
la consommation d'eau par hectare
ce qui ne veut pas dire pour autant
qu'il y aura pas plus d'hectares qui
seront irrégés
donc cette cette base de négociation
vous semble aujourd'hui il faut
l'économie je vous ai dit économie
partage sécurité effectivement il faut
qu'on économise il faut qu'on optimise
l'efficience de l'eau donc diminuer le
besoin par des tout ce qui peut te faire
avant rendre l'eau la plus efficiente
possible on la porte mais on sait que
par rapport au changement climatique
nous constatons tous que nous avons
mesuré il même s'il pleut autant il
pleuvra pas de façon aussi régulière que
par le passé et comme il fait plus chaud
certains moments la plante comme nous a
besoin de plus d'eau au moment donné
donc soit on décide de ne pas produire
et on arrête de produire soit on décide
qu'on doit contribuer à son vote
alimentaire et à ce moment-là il faut
pour apporter de l'eau et cette eau
permettez-moi quand même faire un petit
trois chiffres il tombe un peu plus de
300 milliards de mètres cubes d'eau sur
la France nous en consommons 3 milliards
l'agriculture pour l'irrigation c'est à
dire 1%
je crois que ça fait au moins 5 ou 10
fois qu'on a déjà entendu chiffre mais
pour tout vous dire toute l'eau qui
tombe elle tombe sur la forêt elle tombe
sur des prairies elle tombe etc et elle
est consommée aussi par ailleurs et
aller dans un cycle qui continue et que
quand on revient à la consommation
réelle que ça soit de l'habitant etc on
va revenir aussi un peu à vos chiffres
quelque part voyez ce que je veux dire
la masse d'eau qui tombe sur un
territoire etc on a toujours des
comparatifs à ce niveau là mais très
sincèrement je pense que le fond du
sujet il est il est pas forcément là
aujourd'hui il est sur la ressource
disponible et qu'on peut utiliser les
injustes
il faut savoir en stocker un peu pour la
rendre disponible je prends et je vais
prendre un exemple ce qui se passait ce
qui se passe chez nous en Provence
permettez-moi de parler de ma région
c'est reposons le Verdon sans se
reposons le Verdon les deux tiers de la
population en Provence n'aurait pas sa
place parce que 80% de locaux consommés
dans la région c'est de l'eau qui a été
stocké et transporté l'enlever les
aménagements assez reprend son et du
Verdon 80% 70% de la population n'a pas
sa place chez nous et vous viendrait pas
en vacances chez nous et ce qui s'est
passé la semaine dernière il y a 10
jours en Italie oui c'est ça ce qui
s'est passé en Italie effectivement il y
a eu des morts des inondations s'il y
avait un Serre-Ponçon sur le pot ça se
serait pas passé parce qu'il serait
stocké l'eau ils auraient peut-être
passer la sécheresse un certain moment
et ils auraient moins d'idéation parce
que là durant ça dévasté la Provence à
certaines époques c'est le fleuve fou
comme le mistral fou aujourd'hui elle
est
au moins je dirais un peu régulé et
grâce au stockage mais l'année dernière
nous avons pu passer malgré les tensions
la sèche à l'abri de la sécheresse là où
on peut arroser et cette année il se
reposant est en train de se remplir et
on est relativement serein pour passer
l'été même s'il pleut pas
donc il faut aussi mais monsieur
vice-président globalement
beaucoup de mes collègues ne sont pas
fermés aujourd'hui à ce qui est des
retenus colinéaires stratégiques qui
permettent de freiner l'eau qui ont
aussi des aménités environnementales
mais qui peuvent servir multi-usage et
notamment agricoles sont pas fermés à ça
donc voilà il y a des voix qui peuvent
permettre de trouver aussi des solutions
qui pourraient être acceptables chaque
fois que je
veux quelque part et ça m'arrive de
temps en temps j'effectivement très
attiré pour voir les plans d'autres
comme ça quand j'ai autour d'un plan
d'eau de quelle taille que ce soit il y
a de la vie il y a que souvent des gens
qui font du pédalo de planche à voile il
y a des gens qui pêchent et à la vie là
où il y a pas d'eau mais il y a pas
grand chose c'est très sec et ça brûle
donc il faut aussi se poser la question
comment cette eau qui tombe de façon de
plus en plus irrégulière le climat
méditerranéen qui est notre
particularité d'avoir des pluies très
abondantes à certains moments et
quelques mois sans précipitations nos
anciens ont su le gérer elle est pas
pour commencer ainsi de suite Craponne
et compagnie et puis c'est reposons le
Verdon et donc je pense qu'il y a
vraiment besoin de savoir
domestiquer l'eau en respectant le mieux
attention c'est pas de dire n'importe
quoi
moi aujourd'hui météo de goutte-à-goutte
on laisse des fuites à certains endroits
pour que les abeilles et les oiseaux
puissent voir parce que comme avant on
arrosé gravitairement on avait des
canaux le gibier pouvait boire on les
abeilles pouvaient boire tout le monde
est content on a mis tout ça dans les
tuyaux il y a plus de flaques parce
qu'il y a plus d'aspersion parce qu'il y
a l'aspersion vous avez un peu de FLac
ou des des bordures qui sont mouillés
aujourd'hui le tuyau est enterré dans le
sol pour limiter le maximum
la distribution d'eau pour être la plus
efficace possible à la plante mais pour
satisfaire le besoin les besoins du
gibier et des abeilles il y a des
endroits il y a des fuites
qui valorisent le goutte à goutte parce
que c'est quand même plus coûteux que
une irrigation il faudrait
les légumes mais pour les grandes
cultures c'est plus compliqué
j'ai fait du maïs semence pendant des
années et j'en redoute
les multiplications de semences vous
pouvez les conduire au goutte-à-goutte
même si vous devez un moment donné
passer éventuellement une fois ou deux
de l'aspersion par dessus parce qu'à un
moment donné il faut pouvoir redonner
l'ambiance humide à la plante parce que
le goutte-à-goutte ne suffit pas pour
les questions de vie du pollen mais
sinon vous pouvez et dans certains pays
qui le développent qui le pratique donc
c'est je dis pas que ça va il faut
imaginer qu'on avait du goutte à goutte
partout mais là aussi on peut dire quand
on voit les nouvelles technologies ou
les tracteurs avaient les GPS ils
passent toujours au même endroit vous
avez vos tuyaux qui sont enterrés vous
êtes en non la bourre et vous pouvez
arroser y compris les céréales de vin
je sais que ça risque de choquer mais
c'est pas c'est pas encore le mais ça
peut parce que les technologies si vous
avez du Labour passer partout à le
tracteur vous pouvez pas ouvrir le
tracteur avec des passages bien précis
vous ne repasse toujours même endroit
vous avez une bande de culture vous avez
votre tuyau enterré à 50 cm en
profondeur et ça vous et vous apporter
l'eau la vigne on vient de planter sur
les parcelles expérimentales de la vigne
avait du goutte à goutte enterré à 80 cm
profondeur
parce que si vous le mettez en surface
les racines restent en surface donc
après quand ça sèche c'est fini alors
que là vous mettez l'eau à 42 cm en
profondeur vous faites la liaison
l'humidité remonte et les racines vont
chercher et en plus si vous mettez au
pied des vignes un couvert végétal qui
empêche les vapres aspiration au pied et
que l'intervent est en Hervé que le
tombé vous avez un écran un écran
thermique donc je veux dire les
techniques de les techniques on est on a
encore beaucoup de choses à comprendre à
imaginer et construire parce que lui il
va falloir trouver des solutions
mais la solution c'est pas de dire
moineau cela je suis pas d'accord moins
d'eau à l'hectare oui mais moins d'eau
pour si on veut arriver à produire
préconise quand même de faire des
changes procédés des changements de
culture
quand on nous dit que le maïs prend
l'eau quand justement il y en a moins
l'été et certains disent il vaut mieux
faire du sorgo
c'est ce qu'on entend
ce que vous pensez c'est une solution le
sorgho c'est pas une solution ça peut
être non mais ça le sorgho ça peut sur
des parcelles qui peuvent pas s'arroser
ou si elles avaient pas d'eau et puis
vous verrez bien ce que vous allez
récolter par contre quand vous faites du
maïs l'énergie que vous produisez à
l'hectare ça n'a rien à voir ils sont
c'est bien ça qu'il faut sur il faut
réfléchir qu'est-ce qu'on veut sortir
comme valeur comme énergie parce qu'il
faut tout ramener à l'énergie et c'est
bien le maïs qui est le plus efficient
alors je sais que je suis provocateur en
disant ça monsieur mais je veux pas
mettre du maïs chez nous il y en a pas
mais on s'aperçoit que malgré tout tout
un moment donné peut jouer un rôle
particulier l'évolution des semences
aussi
l'approche sélective etc et on voit que
chaque domaine peut permettre de gagner
en performance et avec des consommations
moindres
c'est pour ça que la recherche est
importante
du varen c'était la recherche
effectivement on attend que ça
s'accélère et on a au passage nous
générons la profession agricole via le
les fonds cazards d'ailleurs la
contribution et nous allons générer
cette année en gros 150 millions de
recettes et nous avons le droit de
l'usage de 125 il y avait 25 millions
qui seront pas utilisables sauf à mener
des
recettes est générée par une pourcentage
du chiffre d'affaires le chiffre
d'affaires d'agriculture ayant augmenté
en 2022 la recette prévisionnelle du
Cazarre sera 250 millions on était à 135
millions d'usages de droits de crédit il
y a quelques années en 2020 ou 21 on a
du covid on a dit ben ça va baisser donc
on a eu droit plus qu'à 125 alors qu'on
a continué à générer 135 l'année
dernière de générer 142 et sa mère va
générer 150 donc on a 25 millions de
marches qui sont des contributions du
monde agricole il est grand temps de les
fléchir sur les opérations de
expérimentation de recherche dans ce
sens-là l'adaptation changement
climatique c'est reparti dans les
caisses de l'État il vous en êtes pas
bénéficiaire l'année dernière grâce au
le ministre a pu en récupérer une grosse
partie on a quand même 20 et quelques
millions qui traînent des années
antérieures qui n'ont pas été utilisés
et là on va générer 25 millions donc
effectivement on demande même pas une
contribution supplémentaire à l'état si
ce n'est de récupérer l'argent que nous
avons généré
c'est pas de dépenses alors oui c'est
une dépense supplémentaire parce qu'il
les a encaissés mais c'est quand même
nous qui les avons générés donc si on
peut les récupérer et augmenter les
travaux de pour accompagner les
agriculteurs ou mener des travaux de
recherche pour trouver des pratiques ou
des variétés ou des conduites qui vont
faire qu'on soit moins exigeant à nous
plus efficients et moins d'eau on aura
on peut le faire bien sûr il y a
toujours eu un plafond de dépenses au
niveau du cadenas et oui on est plein
les plafonnés à 125 millions et en plus
les comptes affectés qui sont le compte
chambre et culture et ACTA et les
instituts on est bloqué et et on a une
inflation que personne conteste tout le
monde sait que ça augmentait et on est
bloqué au même montant qu'il y a 10 ans
en arrière ils font des travaux qu'on
puisse revaloriser et là ça
simplifierait les choses parce que
aujourd'hui on nous dit on va lancer des
appels à projets ils avaient la projet
c'est extraordinaire mais ça demande un
temps pas possible pour les préparer
pour les répondre il faut les examiner
et après derrière éventuellement on est
revenu les sous là on est en capacité je
pense que tu vas te démontrer au moins
sur ce sujet mais on pourrait faire
pareil sur bien d'autres sujets que les
Chambres d'agriculture on est au contact
des agriculteurs pour accompagner et que
dans ce qu'on avait en dotation il y a
il y a 10 ans on est au même montagne
pour accompagner l'évolution du modèle
ça en fait partie sur un fouet très
clair et c'est des stratégies qu'il faut
trouver qui sont amenées dans un monde
idéal il y aurait aujourd'hui une
contractualisation infirmière avec les
régions qui permettraient de mobiliser à
bon escient les fonds qui sont
disponibles les vôtres entre guillemets
au niveau du casse d'art mais pas
exclusivement quand on voit la
contractualisation aussi européenne qui
peut se faire en fonction de la
programmation des régions c'est aussi
des effets déviés supplémentaires ça
permettrait peut-être de faire un peu
moins d'appels à projets mais de créer
des enveloppes plus disponibles et plus
agiles pour intervenir sur des
politiques contractualisées au niveau
régional qu'en pensez-vous sur la partie
oui peut-être
financement de des process de
l'irrigation de qualité etc ça peut
passer par là
une très belle
pour développer les réseaux d'irrigation
la structuration des réseaux les fonds
du fer
qui sont autre que la Pâques recyclée on
a eu pendant quelques années et nos
collègues espagnols pourraient portugais
et autres ont su utiliser les fonds du
FEDER
et nous la France on n'y va pas et c'est
plus il y a plus de programmation donc
s'il y a quelque chose à faire parce que
c'est bien de mettre la fibre optique de
faire les autoroutes des aéroports tout
ce que vous voudrez mais je veux dire la
sécurité
l'eau sur les territoires et pas que
pour les agriculteurs pour tous les
usages pour la consommation humaine pour
la sécurité incendie pour les loisirs
sécuriser l'eau sur les territoires ça
me paraît carrément être une quelque
chose qui va devenir prioritaire alors
il faudrait qu'on puisse remettre dans
la prochaine programmation
FEDER la sécurisation en eau sur les
territoires ça veut bien dire que ça va
tous les à tous les usages pas que nos
agriculteurs effectivement certaines
aménagements
multi-usages pour être financés avec du
FEDER et la partie purement agricole
c'est-à-dire le maillage ou destination
des agriculteurs avec du ferder parce
que le fait ADR c'est quand même de la
pas qu'on a recyclé pourquoi avec la
pacrocyclée d'aménagement des
territoires parce que quand je fais un
réseau d'irrigation multi-usage je le
finance avec du ferder et je serre les
collectivités je veux dire la PAC ok je
veux bien qu'on redistribue et alors
après je vais un peu plus loin parce que
vous avez parlé de des collectivités et
une forme la plus aboutie d'économie
d'eau c'est la révoltaïsme
je vous ai dit que j'avais une serre
photovoltaïque chez moi ça fait cinq ans
et si vous voulez sur votre
considérablement le besoin en eau et
l'exposition au risque et ça c'est la
partie agricole
ça aussi de vertus c'est que ça génère
une taxe qui s'appelle l'hyper
donc si vous prenez l'ifère que je
génère avec mes aménagements photo
agriboltaïques qui vont me permettre de
me protéger des arrivées climatiques et
de réduire ma consommation d'eau et que
vous affectez l'ifère les collectivités
territoriales comme levier pour aller
chercher du FEDER pour faire de la
structuration vous pouvez financer
l'aménagement du territoire sécurisation
à nous sans contribution de l'État
français voilà
la loi
prévoitaïs il y a une forme de
clarification législative récemment
demander à mes collègues s'ils ont
peut-être des questions à ce cette étape
de l'audition parce que là on est parti
un peu mais bon
madame blatrix oui merci président merci
beaucoup monsieur le vice-président pour
ces éléments sur la question de la
protection des captages parce que on
voit bien que c'est un sujet qui monte
il y a des captages prioritaires ou là
en effet il y a un travail qui est fait
pour protéger les captages mais bon on a
eu le problème
est-ce métola chlore on aura d'autres
sujets qui vont arriver donc comment à
votre avis est-ce qu'on je crois que on
nous a dit que c'était seulement trois
pour cent des surfaces agricoles est-ce
que vous nous confirmez ce chiffre et
comment est-ce que vous vous voyez cette
protection des captages et avec quelle
contrepartie pour la profession agricole
la surface qui est concernée de captage
je suis pas le chiffre exact mais je
pense que vous avez vous êtes dans le
vrai c'est ça reste une partie minime
seulement il y a quelques ça concerne
quelquefois une exploitation complète
c'est pas trop pour ça de la saü
répartis à 3% chez tout le monde pour
certains ils peuvent être complètement
dans le périmètre et si on leur met trop
de contraintes déjà que c'est quand même
pas évident parce que si c'était si
facile que ça il y aurait plus
d'installation il y aura moins de départ
moins de suicide donc effectivement il
faut trouver des moyens pour que ceux
qui doivent parce qu'ils sont
positionnés sur un périmètre qui est
d'intérêt général les accompagner dans
des pratiques et que je dis bien les
accompagner moi je suis plutôt favorable
à la carotte au bâton parce que quand on
envoie des contrôleurs chez les
agriculteurs ça coûte très cher quand on
met des PV ça coûte cher et c'est pas
pédagogue c'est pas très pédagogue par
contre quand on accompagne sur des on
met en avant et on la veut dire la loi
accompagne
la fiscalité accompagne ceux qui bio et
ceux qui sont sortis du glyphosate
pourquoi ne pas mettre en place des
systèmes de crédit d'impôts pour ceux
qui ont des pratiques vertueuses et les
accompagner à investir dans des
matériels ou des pratiques qui vont leur
permettre de répondre à cette exigence
là voilà pour moi le le chantier alors
je suis d'une région le problème des
captage le périmètre vous savez de la
France c'est pas majorité c'est pas
notre problème on a quelques-uns mais ça
reste très marginal alors effectivement
il y a aussi des des molécules qui ont
été utilisées à une époque qui ne le
sont plus aujourd'hui mais on sait que
ça peut mettre des fois 10 15 20 30 ans
avant de se résorber parce que c'est
quelque chose qui est très long
on le déplore tous on a tous fait des
erreurs le monde rigole comme les autres
parties de la société moi je suis parti
d'une génération on est certain nombre
ici autre la table quand on était gamins
l'amiante gronder les sandwichs
tellement c'était bien on s'est rendu
compte que c'était la journée
voilà donc effectivement on a mis des
produits de traitement à une époque mais
oui moi j'ai vu mon père avec
comme ça respirer le produit tout le
bord bon et ben oui après il y a des
gens qui ont le maillot de Parkinson
de relation mais il y a quand même
probablement quelque chose oui on a
commis des erreurs c'est comme les
voitures mais à une époque ce qui
comptait c'était la vitesse à laquelle
roulait aujourd'hui on regarde ce
qu'elle aimait comme comme gaz
carbonique donc
[Musique]
Monsieur Louis Jean de Nicolas oui merci
j'ai toujours sur les captages
de ma commune j'étais mère d'une commune
de 4300 habitants la consommation d'eau
c'était 300000 mètres cubes par an un
agriculteur c'est 60 000 mètres cubes
par an donc 5 agriculteurs c'était à peu
près l'équivalent de la consommation
d'eau de la population c'est vrai que
l'eau revient sur la terre etc à votre
avis pour passer de l'enrouleur entre
guillemets qui est le truc simple pour
pour l'agriculteur
vers le le goutte à goutte entre
guillemets
l'investissement est de combien la
transformation est combien parce que ils
vont nous dire automatiquement si c'est
impossible à faire pour nous avec
même avec les 140% d'amortissement et
autres
choses sur les aime et c'est pour ça
quel est le montant de à l'hectare ou
est-ce qu'on peut le savoir est-ce que
vous pensez que vous pouvez le savoir ça
ou pas je peux des idées de coupes à
l'hectare ça il y a pas de souci mais ça
dépend de la culture ça dépend si vous
êtes avec
5000 m
je
peux je peux vous le chiffrer
et après parce qu'il y a le goutte à
goutte dans la parcelle il y a tout le
matériel d'amener de distribution les
électrovannes
et le travail
la question de Louis Jean elle est aussi
intéressante vous comprenez pour nous
parce que même si les chiffres ils sont
effectivement importants ils seront
toujours discutés etc mais ça permet de
voir globalement ce qu'il faudrait faire
pour être dans une gestion optimisée et
après ça interroge les politiques
publiques quelle qu'elle soit pour voir
comment on met en place les stratégies
d'accompagnement c'est la même chose
pour nous sur le petit cycle pour dire
comment va résorber les fuites ou amener
à un système de performance qui va nous
amener à 90% plutôt qu'à 80 aujourd'hui
il voyait c'est la même chose parce que
après c'est pas si simple que ça parce
que le goutte-à-goutte vous avez la
taille des parcelles si vous avez très
grande parcelle la longueur elle est
limitée c'est il faut pratiquement
prendre la parcelle et faire l'étude à
la parcelle si votre parcelle est un
carré ou un rectangle c'est pas le même
prix
la même surface donc
l'évaluation même si elle est elle reste
une évaluation au niveau national elle
serait intéressante parce que ça
permettrait de se dire est-ce que dans
le programme d'accompagnement la montée
en qualité en performance du réseau
qu'est-ce qu'il faut mettre ou qu'est-ce
qu'il faudrait contractualiser au niveau
des politiques publiques
on peut regarder vos données quelques
chiffres de façon précise parce que moi
j'ai si on parle des tomates je sais
vous calculez je suis même plus le prix
parce que c'est plus moi qui m'en occupe
ça va bien augmenter ces dernières
années et malheureusement il s'est pas
éligible pour opérationnel ce qui est
une catastrophe et la tomate de Marmande
vient voir son label rouge mais ça c'est
pour moi c'est la tomate d'autres
questions monsieur gold
300 m de côte 300 km de côte
alors il y a des pays qui ont justement
essayé de
de contrer le fait qu'il manque de l'eau
on mis en des systèmes de désalinisation
vous est-ce que c'est quelque chose que
vous avez un jour abordé
alors
c'est clair que la cote chez nous c'est
pas trop le domaine de la chambre
régionale parce que c'est d'abord le
tourisme c'est surtout l'urbanisation
bien que l'agriculture sur le Lacoste
sur Nice ou effectivement il y a des
horticulteurs sur des petites
exploitations des petites surfaces mais
à forte intensité
sur la déstabilisation
chez nous c'est pas le problème
dans le sud de la France pour l'instant
parce que grâce aux aménagements qui ont
été faits par ces reposons et le Verdon
nous sommes quasiment à l'abri du risque
de manque d'eau je dis pas qu'il faudra
pas y aller là aussi mais c'est pas du
c'est pas notre préoccupation majeure
parce que
on a la chance d'avoir un système qui
peut-être sera
évolué il satisfera pas demain les
besoins mais pour l'instant je veux dire
on est surtout axé sur quoi arrive quand
même la préoccupation de la
réutilisation des eaux usées surtout en
zone littorale ou en zone urbaine parce
que et le problème c'est que le fait le
problème
l'usage agricole il est pas forcément à
côté des villes
et
on regarde le volume qui est généré par
les stations d'épuration vous le
regardez sur l'année et nous on a besoin
sur deux mois qu'est-ce que vous faites
vous stocker l'eau de station
d'épuration vous me la remontez de 9100
km pour que je puisse l'utiliser et vous
et on prend pas l'eau qui passe je pense
que c'est plus raisonnable de prendre
l'eau qui circule qu'on l'économise
qu'on stocke quand elle passe pour un
garder un peu plus parce que on a la
chance d'avoir des précipitations
il y a des pays il y a des alors pour
certains usages et je pense que les là
où il y a plus à faire que dans
l'agriculture c'est les collectivités
pour les jardins espaces verts les
stades lavage des voiries et tout ce qui
s'ensuites où sont des usages qui ne
sont pas des usages alimentaires parce
que quand on est dans l'agriculture
alimentaire
même si on nous dit que c'est sécurisé
tous ces trucs et après il y a le coût
parce que si vous voulez rendre l'eau de
station d'épuration utilisable sur des
productions alimentaires le coût ça va
timeler excusez-moi le terme ça va
coûter cher par contre pour laver de la
voirie pourquoi vous dites ça parce que
à l'heure actuelle les sorties au niveau
des stations d'épuration quand les
stations d'épuration sont vraiment
conformes etc
vous en faites quoi
et oui et oui c'est une médicament sur
le vice-président vous les retrouvez
déjà dans l'eau que vous prélevez non
vous mettez vous mettez déjà que le
Rhône est bien chargé en tout un tas de
matière mais alors effectivement
je sais qu'il y avait un chantier
d'expérimentation de mettre des stations
de traitement des eaux usées à la sortie
des hôpitaux parce que le là où il y a
le plus de résidus médicamenteux ou je
sais pas le terme exact mais c'est bien
dans les hôpitaux ou les ou les
établissements pour les personnes de
soins quoi donc là effectivement pour
pas avoir à traiter complètement tout un
volume d'eau
de façon très coûteuse parce que vous
devez au zoner l'eau ou passer pendant
des trucs ultraviolets ça coûte très
cher ça va rendre le prix de l'eau qui
n'est pas utilisable sur le plan
agricole
non mais ça peut être valable que pour
les grandes cultures le limite
il y a un coût après pour l'amener des
canalisations pour aller jusqu'au
parcelles c'est sûr
et les cahiers des charges vont
interdisent d'utiliser des boules de
station d'épuration mais interdiront
d'utiliser
on me pose le même des questions sur la
qualité de l'eau du rhum
et oui donc
on a bien cette année si on a voulu le
sauver madame on a bien été obligé on a
semblé des pois chiches parce qu'on n'a
pas arrosé parce qu'il a pas plu pendant
deux mois du mois de février jusqu'à
faire avril le début mai oui mais c'est
ça
mais
c'est là où je sais pas ce qu'on
souhaite attention que je souhaite pas
arroser le blé parce que c'est parce que
ça nous va nous coûter cher parce que
quand on a ouvert la borne quand j'ouvre
la borne ou que j'appuie sur
l'interrupteur où je tourne la clé du
groupe je sais que le compteur est
financier tourne moi si je pouvais lever
la charge de l'irrigation et le temps
qu'on passe à l'irrigation sur
l'exploitation mais qu'est-ce qu'on se
revient à condition que je me rendement
agronomique à la sortie parce que là où
j'arrose pas j'ai pas le même
l'arrosage du blé c'est quand même
exceptionnel mais on a bien été
contraint et ce qu'on a pas arrosé
on va courir la peine là il y aura pas
grand-chose la moissonneuse
monsieur tout à l'heure vous avez dit
on n'est pas moi je suis pas là pour
diriger l'ensemble des chambres
d'agriculture chaque chambre
d'agriculture fait ce qu'elle a envie de
faire
vous vous concertez pas pour savoir si
éventuellement il y a des régions de
France où il y aurait il vaudrait mieux
faire telle ou telle pratique pour que
vous puissiez réfléchir tous ensemble à
l'utilisation de l'eau justement parce
que autant je comprends que vous
arrosiez vos tomates parce que mais le
blé peut-être qu'il y a d'autres régions
de France qui pourraient faire plus de
blé et pas autre chose moi je vois par
exemple chez moi c'est c'est de la craie
ils se sont mis tous à faire des pommes
de terre c'est normal ça payait mieux
ils ont fait des pommes de terre sauf
que maintenant ils arrosent donc ça va
pas non plus donc je pense qu'il
faudrait quand même qu'il y ait une
concertation générale
madame si vous savez me donner les six
bons numéros loto ça m'arrangerait parce
que moi la météo je sais pas la gérer je
la suivi effectivement nous avons suivi
pendant trois mois des excès de pluie à
l'automne nous avons les inondations sur
novembre décembre et on était en déficit
hydrique difficile de polyométrie fin
octobre et on a dépassé au 31 décembre
les précipitations moyennes voilà des
champs qui se sont inondés les cultures
sont parties et puis au mois de janvier
s'est arrêté de pleuvoir et jusqu'à au
15 mai il a pas plu et là les céréales
mais ils n'ont pas poussé
les pois chiches n'ont pas poussé mais
pas juste je voyais courir dans la paix
au milieu et après depuis 15 jours
depuis trois semaines il pleut et nous
avons dépassé les précipitations en 15
jours du mois de mai en moyenne et nous
sommes le 5 juin au 6 juin aujourd'hui
et nous avons déjà dépassé des
précipitations moyennes de juin ça c'est
sur trois semaines fin mai début juin
dans le sud mes collègues sont dans le
haut de France voilà ou de France il y a
trois semaines en mois quand on se
parlait il pouvait pas planter les
pommes de terre il pouvait pas semer
parce qu'il faisait que de pleuvoir il
rentre pas dans les champs et là il faut
qu'ils arrosent parce que ça a séché
donc la météo elle est complètement
déréglée et nous devons si nous nous
voulons répondre à notre mission qui
nous est confiée nous agriculteurs de
pouvoir vous apporter dans l'assiette
tous les jours quelque chose pouvoir
essayer d'atténuer les caprices du
climat de la météo et pour ça mais il
faut qu'on puisse éventuellement évacuer
de l'eau dans les parcelles quand il y
en a trop c'est le drainage il faut
pouvoir apporter quand il est en déficit
parce que sinon il y aura pas grand
chose
ça veut dire aussi
effectivement les couverts végétaux le
nom labour
favorise le la structuration du sol la
vie la vie dans le sol et tout ça on
voit bien que dès qu'on arrête de
labourer et qu'on laisse du végétal au
bout de trois quatre ans on a une vie
les vers de terre et c'est énorme
seulement si vous l'avouerez pas un
moment donné vous avez des espèces que
vous n'arrivez plus à contrôler donc la
solution c'est la rampe
donc c'est pour ça que je veux dire moi
les donneurs de leçon
qui viennent voilà
de vous répondre comme ça mais c'est
pour vous montrer que c'est pas si
simple que ça et là on a la
démonstration mais mes collègues de
France
il y a trois semaines il y a un mois
quand on se parlait il me dit on peut
pas travailler on n'arrive pas à planter
les pommes de terre monsieur le
Président si vous le permettez
il y a des variations de plus en plus
fortes mais en même temps
la stratégie pour une meilleure
connaissance au niveau des modèles même
climatiques etc il faut conforter avec
l'intelligence aussi numérique etc même
si on sait que ça sera complexe il n'en
demeure pas moins que on peut s'accorder
pour que plus on avancera mieux on
connaîtra malgré tout ces sujets là mis
en le maîtrisera donc l'approche
stratégique quelque part dont parle
Évelyne elle est intéressante malgré
tout au niveau culture un des éléments
aussi qui manque aujourd'hui c'est vous
êtes dépendant bien sûr des marchés vous
pouvez pas semer ne pas pouvoir vendre
quelque part donc il peut y avoir des
nouvelles céréales des nouveaux
assolements mais encore faut-il qu'elle
marchait derrière et là on a le
sentiment on a du mal à voir comment
ces évolutions sont vraiment
accompagnées ou organisé en d'autres
termes il peut y avoir des nouveaux
marchés qui émergent mais il faut aussi
les accompagner et derrière cet
accompagnement de l'évolution des
nouveaux marchés il faut que les choses
puissent se mettre en place correctement
on a vu par exemple sur certaines
cultures c'est pas la panacée on le sait
mais c'est des cultures intermédiaires
qui peuvent être intéressantes comme le
chanvre bon change peut être intéressant
mais encore faut-il que tout soit bien
organisé derrière et que le marché soit
bien organisé mais que la valorisation
des matières soit si bien organisée
derrière si c'est pas bien organisé ça
peut être une très bonne idée mais on
n'y arrive pas
[Musique]
et pourtant c'est pas forcément idiot
c'est
pas forcément après
oui mais chez toi il y a une filière qui
se met en place derrière maintenant
si on peut faire tout un tas de culture
diversification à destination de la des
agromatériaux ou autre
la mission fondamentale c'est quand même
de produire la nourriture
du tournesol des pommes de terre des
légumes des trucs comme ça on peut pas
effectivement si vous voulez passer qui
a des cultures sans irrigation ça pousse
bien
je m'interroge sur cette nouvelle
pratique est-ce que vous pensez pas que
c'est une pratique qui mériterait d'être
encadrée parce que moi je vois par
exemple dans mon département où on a
plutôt des fermes familiales si vous
voulez beaucoup de paysans sont en
affermage
le propriétaire à un moment donné si je
regarde cette nouvelle pratique le
propriétaire à un moment donné peut être
beaucoup plus intéressé par le fait
d'installer des panneaux photovoltaïques
sur son terrain que d'avoir le loyer du
fermier je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez mais je pense que c'est une
pratique moi qui m'interroge alors
il faut déjà dissocier les deux il y a
ce qu'on appelle la grive voltaïsme qui
est la combinaison de la production
agricole et la production d'énergie
photovoltaïque sur la même parcelle et
là on sert en BR Ière au meilleur pour
les animaux ça permet de combiner les
deux et la somme des deux est supérieure
à 1 et la loi prévoit que ça doit
apporter un plus à la production
agricole débuter à 20% de chiffre
d'affaires limité à 20% de chiffre
pour l'instant il y a moi j'ai pas de
connaissance de limitation de chiffre
d'affaires je vais vous prendre le cas
chez moi moi la photo la serre ne me
rapporte rien puisque j'ai mis le sol à
disposition de l'aménageur qui a
construit la serre pendant 30 ans il va
exploiter la serre et moi pendant 30 ans
je bénéficie la serre gratuitement
je n'ai aucune aucun retour sur
l'énergie par contre j'ai un outil qui
coûte 4 millions
de travailler dans des conditions de
travail qui ne sont pas celles d'une
séance au plastique et j'ai pas du
plastique à recycler tous les quatre
temps c'est nettement mieux
après quand vous parlez des photos
allzaïques au sol c'est à dire quand il
n'y a pas de production de sous alors là
effectivement pour l'instant nous nous
sommes opposés à ce cette pratique là
si le loyer en avoir et malheureusement
je crains qu'il y avait il faut qu'on
mette un système de régulation sur le
sur le pratiquant donc il a proposition
que nous faisons alors je suis encore
pas encore rejoint pour l'instant je ne
peux pas complètement Laval de tout le
monde c'est de dire les cinq premières
hectares
de photovoltaïque au sol le propriétaire
récupère la totalité de la rémunération
parce qu'il y a plus de production
agricoles il récupère la totalité à
partir de la 5e hectare et au-delà il
reçoit un fermage à 1000 euros lecteurs
et la différence vient sur un bien aller
dans un Buffin agricole géré par les
chambres de la culture sous le contrôle
du préfet et avec ça on finance des
projets à haute investissement
capitalistique ou innovant ou autre le
magasin de produits fermiers au bénéfice
de l'agriculture sur le territoire parce
qu'on va créer de la richesse sur le
territoire agricole et la richesse va
partir alors que le monde agricole le
territoire du vol a besoin donc si on
crée de la richesse alors les cinq
premières hectares parce que cinq
hectares à 5000 euros ça fait 25000
euros ça fait une retraite correcte pour
le propriétaire au delà et là on va
limiter ceux qui sont en train de
vouloir acheter deux trois quatre cinq
hectares pour développer des
photosvoltaïques et ramasser et et
rémunéré peut-être des actionnaires du
CAC 40
et je suis pas communiste je pragmatique
et je veux que l'argent qui est généré
non mais je sais pas non mais c'est
dommage
je sortais un peu du cadre mais c'est
pas moi je considère que on a
l'agriculture l'espace agricole l'espace
agricole va contribuer à la production
énergétique c'est une manne il faut
qu'on puisse en ramener au bénéfice de
l'agriculture à installer des jeunes
dans des conditions difficiles permettre
des investissements coûteux pour de la
transformation des magasins fermiers
peut-être accompagner la mise en
irrigation à certains endroits parce que
aujourd'hui mais on est limité en
moyenne en moyenne pour le faire voilà
et l'ifère j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
l'hiver qui est généré c'est les
collectivités que l'on récupère et il
faut que l'on réinjecte sur le
territoire parce que c'est une richesse
qu'on va créer sur l'espace agricolaire
rural il faut que je te richesse la
revienne au bénéfice de ce territoire
j'ai absolument rien contre les stades
et les crèches et tout ce que vous
voulez d'autres mais il faut que ça
revienne au territoire
ça nous intéresse aussi on va bien sûr
il y a pas de souci on va interroger un
peu le son
je crois que c'est tout notre question
monsieur Bruyer
non je veux bien j'écoute votre
plaidoyer pour le monde agricole qui est
construit et solide
moi je suis écologiste
que vous étiez un des meilleurs
défenseurs de de la nature mais on vous
écoutant monsieur le Président on mesure
à quel point les perturbations du cycle
météo et du cycle climatique vous
impacte
tout à l'heure j'ai réagi quand vous
parliez il y a un peu trop de monde dans
les ptge tout ça des gens parce que ils
font pas l'agriculture mais
j'ai réagi parce que c'est quand même à
80% les consommateurs qui payent les
sujets de dépollution moi je suis un
francilien par exemple
le sédive va consacrer un milliard à la
dépollution de l'eau c'est pas que aucun
problème d'agriculture c'est un problème
de dépollution de l'eau mais quand même
il n'empêche que je me dis cette
dépollution si on était capable de
mettre cet argent dans la production on
parlait des zones de captage détente des
zones de captage mieux produit et de
rémunérer vous vous produisez de l'eau
qu'on mange il y a l'eau qu'on boit et
vous vous produisez de l'eau qu'on mange
à travers l'alimentation donc moi je me
dis j'aimerais mieux quand même qu'on
essaye d'éviter d'avoir à dépolluer et
du coup ma question est la suivante
comment vous voyez avec cette crise
climatique qui s'aggrave cette tension
sur les pesticides les herbicides qui
sont un problème de santé publique qu'on
ne peut pas nier non plus comment vous
voyez les évolutions et est-ce qu'il des
mesures moi je suis très favorable à des
mesures d'accompagnement qui
permettraient que nous n'ayons pas en
aval à traiter des sujets et par
ailleurs avoir des affrontements entre
les citoyens qui alors que les
agriculteurs les nourrissent disent ils
nous ils nous punissent aussi par
l'usage de ces pesticides etc donc je
pense qui je me permets de dire ça parce
que je vous ai senti très
défenseur c'est votre rôle du monde
agricole mais je pense qu'en fait on a
un sujet collectif qui est d'avancer sur
un meilleur partage la ressources une
diminution des intrants des pesticides
des herbicides une meilleure protection
de la santé et sans doute des circuits
courts et sur le maïs j'ai pas forcément
la même appréciation que vous parce
qu'on en exporte quand même beaucoup et
on l'utilise
beaucoup aussi ne me dites pas le
contraire
et tout
ouais c'est pas tellement pour
l'alimentation mais enfin mon passion
du bétail etc et revenons sur la
première planète
[Musique]
on aime bien les uns les autres quand on
est là on aime bien les mèches aussi
par rapport à votre préoccupation
comment on peut rendre l'agriculture
moins impactante c'est ça question
alors effectivement on a eu le Varenne
il y avait trois thèmes dans le varen
c'était comment on accompagne les
agriculteurs en cas de sinistre face au
changement climatique c'est le système
assurantiel qui se met en place qui a
encore besoin d'évoluer mais qui est
déjà un grand pas deuxièmement le volume
2 du Varennes c'était c'est comment on
améliore la performance de l'agriculture
en intensifiant les travaux de recherche
pour que on est des variétés résistantes
des cultures qui sont capables de
tolérer tel ou telle maladie ou telle ou
tel ravageur et tout ça c'est en train
de se mettre en place il y a des
variétés il y a des espèces qui sont
plus ou moins le centre de l'autre
comment par des pratiques qu'on va
mettre au point on peut arriver à
améliorer encore les choses comment avec
la robotique et l'agriculture de
précision on va diminuer
probablement peut-être pas complètement
supprimés mais diminuer fortement
peut-être ne pas se ne pas faire au
recours aux
désherbant chimiques parce que la
technique le permet aujourd'hui quand
vous avez des possibilités de semer au
centimètre près d'aller se ressemer la
congés juste à côté de moi après ou
trois mois après ça c'est quand même une
révolution quand vous avez des caméras
qui sont capables de détecter la plante
de passer autour du pied de salade ou
autre c'est des évolutions seulement ça
ça nécessite encore des travaux de mise
au point et de vulgarisation auprès des
agriculteurs et l'accompagnement à
l'investissement parce qu'effectivement
c'est
venir au robot dans le champ de tomates
effectivement il avance seul
à faire évoluer mais quand vous annonce
le prix vous partez vous dis c'est bon
quoi parce que c'est pas c'est alors
effectivement il faut payer la recherche
les gars ils travaillent pendant des
années des années avant d'avoir l'outil
qui correspond ils veulent vous faire
payer sur les premiers modèles tout ça
donc c'est pas il faut qu'on trouve le
juste oui la technologie le numérique le
robotique l'agriculture de précision
tout ça ça va contribuer à diminuer
l'usage de certains de certaines
désherbants en particulier les variétés
résistantes ou tolérantes aux maladies
aussi on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui par
des évolutions
sélection ou le croisement je parle pas
d'OGM et annoncé
pour trouver le vaccin pour le covid
pourquoi on utilise pas pour avancer sur
les sur les plantes pour se débarrasser
de certains ravagesurs il y a certaines
des espèces aujourd'hui qui ne sont plus
sensibles au virus parce que sur un plan
de melon par exemple alors il faut y
aller avec le loupe pour le voir la tige
c'est que des que des que des films dont
le pucerons il peut pas les piquer donc
la virose se propage plus voilà mais ça
c'est c'est des trucs qui ont été mis
sur le mélange que je connais pareil sur
la tomate on a aujourd'hui pu développer
la production bio ou diminuer le
traitement parce qu'on a des variétés
résistantes et qui reste qui reste au
champ en capacité d'être récolté trois
semaines
mais ça c'est bien la recherche qui nous
la
mette de loi d'Orient de l'argent pour
financer de la recherche fondamentale
accompagne le recherche de haut niveau
et que derrière nous on puisse avec les
moyens que nous générons poursuivre le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui il y a
plus les moyens de ce côté-là par contre
au sanctionne qu'est-ce qui se passe à
la finitionner bien on se retrouve que
certaines productions disparaissent de
l'échiquier français et on va vers une
simplification vers quelques cultures
qui ont encore les technologies qui ont
encore les moyens de se le produire
parce qu'effectivement elle garde les
les moyens de se protéger il y a un
certain nombre de légumes qui ont
disparu de France parce que il y a plus
les moyens de les protéger
oui c'est le problème des close miroir
aussi qui sont posées aussi à ce niveau
là il y a une question peut-être parce
qu'on a brossé pas mal non non non non
non pas du tout bien au contraire parce
que on sait qu'on est dans une globalité
aujourd'hui quand on parle de ces sujets
là et donc il y a pas de il n'y a pas de
problème donc il y a une question qui
nous intéressait sur l'usage agricole de
l'eau dans le cadre de la concertation
du pacte et loi d'orientation agricole
donc est-ce que vous avez des éléments
par rapport à ça puisque c'est en cours
de négociation
je vais prendre l'exemple que je connais
bien chez moi en région sud il y a eu
trois groupes de travail sur
l'installation sur la formation et un
sur l'eau et l'adaptation changement
climatique
le groupe qui travaillait sur
l'adaptation changement climatique la
gestion de l'eau à lui tout seul a fait
plus que les deux autres groupes donc
c'est bien la preuve que j'ai une
sensibilité très forte du monde agricole
au changement climatique et à la gestion
de l'eau
sur que c'est combien 11 régions sur 13
je crois qu'ils ont 9 régions sur 13 qui
ont mis la problématique de l'eau en
avant parce qu'effectivement c'est bien
le problème majeur parce qu'il y a des
sujets sur lequel c'est difficile d'agir
par contre le paysan ne comprennent pas
que quand il y a de l'eau on puisse pas
la stocker pour l'utiliser quand elle
est nécessaire et ça c'est ça le vrai ne
comprennent pas vous voyez russe le dos
alors j'ai pas l'article mais il paraît
que il y a un article hier dans la
presse chez nous c'est pas national mais
c'est régional qui vendent le mérite des
particuliers qui économisent l'eau et
qui
[Musique]
des imperméabilisent leur sol et qui
stockent depuis
c'est formidable oui mais c'est
formidable si un particulier mais 5 m3
sur 5000 mètres dans son exploitation
pour alimenter 4 ou 5 hectares on prend
l'exemple donné le beurre
il fait que du foin il passera pas
il va labourer 4 hectares 4 ou 5
hectares de l'exploitation il va faire
une retenue de 5000 mètres sur ces 5
hectares avec ça il va produire la
plante magique qui est le maïs ou des
betteraves et il aura son autonomie
fourragère parce que celui qui fait que
du foin quand il pleut pas et bien il a
recours au foyer en Espagne je sais pas
ce qu'ils vont on a la chance il pleut
on n'a jamais autant d'herbes qui
poussent que cette année voilà sur la
zone la zone concernée par
l'élevage ça n'est il y a énormément de
foin la pousse l'air est à 15% au dessus
de la moyenne des cinq dernières années
un peu respirer mais là aussi je veux
dire il y a des mois je connais des
agriculteurs qui chaque année ils sont
en train de pleurer pour avoir les
indemnités sécheresse au passage je vous
rappelle que les deux tiers depuis 15
ans les deux tiers du fond de calamité
agricole versé aux agriculteurs c'est
par rapport à la sécheresse il fait 80%
de ces ennemis de là sont versés aux
éleveurs parce qu'ils n'ont pas assez de
foin pour nourrir leurs bêtes alors que
s'ils prennent 7% de leur surface de
leur exploitation et qu'il fasse une
qu'il forme une culture
pour alimenter leur troupeau des
betteraves du maïs ou d'autres cultures
qui vont irriguer avec l'eau qui
ruisselle parce que c'est bien souvent
de récupérer l'eau qui ruisselle leur
exploitation donc il le stocke il y a
les Allemands
de toute façon vous vous l'avez indiqué
quelque part déjà un peu dans vos propos
quand vous avez cité
délégation que vous pratiquez là vous
faisiez les prélèvements et
effectivement vous revenez au niveau du
ruissellement je pense qu'on peut avoir
un intérêt à récolter une eau qui
ruisselle de manière excessive pour la
stocker à bon escient et qu'elle puisse
il n'y a pas de souci par contre une eau
qui est prélevée dans une nappe en tant
que
on est d'accord
je pense qu'on est d'accord là dessus
vous entraînez d'accord vous avez des
territoires vous avez des ruisseaux vous
avez de l'eau qui coule dans des
ruisseaux qui vont dans des rivières et
vous avez des sols qui sont des sols
l'eau s'infiltre il n'y a pas de cours
d'eau par contre la nappe elle est à 3 5
10 15 20 mètres c'est une nappe qui se
recharge et qui fait ça chaque année
quand les au-dessus d'un certain niveau
quand une éponge est bien pleine si vous
prenez un peu d'eau l'éponge existe
encore
et c'est tout que vous avez aspiré de
l'épaule jusqu'à est en excès vous la
mettez dans un réservoir étanche on peut
pas citer le mot qui fait pleurera tout
le monde et vous la reprenez qu'on en
avait besoin par contre si vous la
prenez pas un moment donné elle va
acheter elle va ressortir plus loin et
vous connaissez vous connaissez le débat
là-dessus la nappe se met sous pression
elle a ensuite des répartitions d'une
manière importante sur son sur son
bassin versant elle va rendre aussi des
usages etc
s'évaporer aussi pour partie donc on
voit bien que des stratégies plus
vertueuses que d'autres et vous le savez
vous seriez président
important et que vous pouvez la repomper
c'est le meilleur endroit pour la
stocker parce que le s’évapore pas elle
reste fraîche mais c'est pas partout si
je veux dire ça dépend il y a pas je
pense pas je suis même sûr qu'on ne peut
pas dire qu'il y a un modèle donc chaque
territoire dans chaque territoire en
fonction de sa pédagogie de son sol il
se vice-président vous pouvez être sûr
que c'est un des constats qui est posé
par la mission il y a pas de dogme il y
a à chaque fois faut regarder les
territoires donc
on est d'accord on est d'accord
[Musique]
de France ils comprenait pas qu'on les
empêche de prendre l'eau parce qu'il me
dit on va descendre mais on sait que
pendant l'hiver ça va remonter ça va
excusez-moi l'expression
donc pourquoi à un moment donné je peux
pas descendre 50 cm résultat mais je
ferai pas meilleur écho alors si
effectivement il pleut pas que la nappe
se recharge pas l'année suivante je
dégraderai pas la situation mais jusqu'à
preuve du contraire chaque année ça se
recharge
et pourquoi on se dit mais non stop
alors maintenant on leur dit oui il va
falloir pomper pour faire des réserves
et vous la reprendrez l'été
d'où la nécessité de bien connaître les
nappes de toute façon c'est une
stratégie vide
excusez-moi si vos propos on peut vous
choquer mais je parle directement
non non mais merci pour cet échange très
intéressant et
des débats sont toujours en France
direct mais très respectueux
il y a aucun souci
on aime ce qu'on fait et tout le monde
d'ailleurs aime est impliquée mais quand
même monsieur je que vous êtes très très
optimiste par rapport à aux eaux du
Verdon et tout ça parce que la semaine
dernière nous avons reçu des camarguais
et ils ont les eaux du Rhône et quand
même ils étaient très très inquiets
parce que ça coule beaucoup moins ça
coule beaucoup moins le rouge et j'étais
au bord du Serre-Ponçon l'été dernier il
fallait faire un sacré bout de chemin
pour avoir un peu d'eau donc les
touristes du qui sont autour du
Serre-Ponçon ils étaient quand même pas
très très content
de se reposons et on a continué à
amplifier les erreurs puisque moi au
mois d'avril
on a commencé à mettre des restrictions
on a commencé à se mettre des
restrictions nous le monde agricole
parce que l'eau de la Durance elle est
gérée en bas sur le Vaucluse et les
Bouches-du-Rhône par une qui s'appelle
la commission exécutive de l'endurance
qui est une loi qui date 1907 qui
répartit lourd entre les usages
agricoles et la ville de Marseille et
quand on a fait la réunion à sous
l'autorité de Monsieur le Préfet
l'adréal a demandé à appliquer ce qui
est prévu normalement puisque le débit
réservé de la Durance il y a 9 mètres
cubes seconde du mois de décembre
jusqu'à fin mars c'est 15 mètres cubes
seconde du premier avril au 30 juillet
au 1er juillet et c'est 5 m3 du mois de
juillet je commence
nous étions l'année dernière dès le mois
de février en tension sur ses reponçons
le monde agricole s'est mis en redonne
marche pour dès le mois de avril réduire
ses prélèvements et on est quand même à
les mettre les 9 les 15 m3 dans la
Durance du mois d'avril jusqu'au 15 juin
parce que le préfet a fini par nous
entendre on a perdu trois mètres 3
mètres pourquoi pour avoir une débit
réservée qui correspondait à un idéal
dans une année normale mais on est dans
une année de sécheresse on le sait on le
voit on sait qu'il y a pas de neige et
là on large quand même de l'eau parce
que les poissons dans la Durance ils
auraient très bien pu vivre avec 9 m ils
avaient pas besoin de 15 et on a perdu
trois mètres oui l'année dernière il y a
eu une difficulté à ce moment-là c'est
parce que le débit réservé mal calculé
parce que le débit réservé il est
réservé justement pour préserver le
biotope le débit réservé il se qui
s'apprécie sur les 5 ou 6 ou 10 ans en
arrière vous prenez les références il y
a 10 ans pour quelques débit réservés
d'aujourd'hui je me suis accroché le
projet l'adré et j'y m'attendais s'il y
a moins d'eau globalement il va bien
falloir revoir la totalité du délai
réservé
il pleut moins vous avez moins d'eau et
vous gardez le même débit réservé il y a
un problème ça peut pas fonctionner sous
couvercle on maintient bien le biotope
quand même
à 5 m à 5 m3 à 5 mètres cubes à 5 mètres
cubes il y a la vie parce que s'il y
avait passé reposante il y aurait pas de
débit réserver dans la Durance
certainement ça c'est donc voilà donc un
moment donné il faut
on est bien d'accord
le système agricole vous savez vous
savez après on parle beaucoup de
l'agriculture des 60 rurales mais on
pourrait quand même regarder aussi ce
qui s'est passé depuis 50 ans le nombre
de mètres carrés qu'on a imperméabilisé
qu'on a bétonné qui fait une
accélération de l'eau à un moment donné
et puis les parkings et les parkings
souterrains qui font qu'on abaisse la
nappe voilà et puis la pollution et la
pollution dont personne ne parle encore
mais un jour ça va sortir ça va nous
excusez-moi péter la figure c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des particules
fines de pneumatiques qui sont usées
tous les jours parce qu'en vous achetez
un peu comme ça et qu'au bout de 6 mois
il est plus que ça c'est bien passé
quelque part
donc c'est pas ça c'est pas
l'agriculture les pollutions dans le
Rhône la presse les deux principales
pollutions dans le Rhône c'est les PCB
et c'est des médicaments c'est pas
l'agriculture donc effectivement on part
systématiquement des phytos parce que
c'est facile de dire que c'est les
paysans mais quand on veut regarder les
choses un peu comme il faut alors là
s'arrête c'est comme la réutilisation
des eaux usées moi j'y banco le jour où
vous le mettrez sur vos salades et que
les bio mangeront vos salades vous on
arrosera deux des salades bio et que
vous les mangerez et que vous me
garantirez qu'il y a pas de problème je
peux y aller mais pour l'instant je
prendrai pas le risque donc d'amener les
agriculteurs à la réutilisation des eaux
usées sur certaines cultures tant que
c'est pas garantie
oui mais attendez attendez merci à vous
merci merci tu m'excuse